I burst the door and run up the stairs
in my hands I'm clutching on to a brand
new box of general-purpose Legos I set
them down on the floor my brother
scurries in behind me and plops down
next to me we open the box whoa look at
all the pieces our imaginations are
racing we dump out the Box pieces are
all over the floor we're thinking hmm
what are we going to make and we start
to build and we build and we deconstruct
and we build some more until by the end
of it the whole floors spreading across
the whole floor is a giant lego city we
are excited we're looking at it with a
little bit of be relevant this is fun so
i'm sure that at some point in your
childhood you've had similar feelings of
awe or bewilderment excitement
excitement about discovery creating
something or just learning something new
whether you built a fort or sang a new
song or something of the sort take
yourself back to that moment and
reimagine those feelings now fast
forward you're an adult the specter of
responsibility washes over you like a
tide so you still have some curiosity
but largely tracked paths and societal
structures are getting in your way you
don't really feel that youthful sense of
awe or exuberance anymore and this is
tragic it's tragic for you and it's
tragic for society you see our ability
to innovate and create and change the
world's a society is heavily dependent
on our creative ability our imagination
our desire to build if you look at the
historical record we can find many
examples
societies that have fallen by the
wayside when they've lost their ability
to create to innovate to imagine let's
take an example take yourself back to
the sixth century BC this is the Persian
Empire you're in the capital city of
Persepolis you're looking around in
amazement at the wonderful monuments and
sculptures statues great architecture
everywhere you also know that you're
protected by the most innovative
military in history which is an
accumulation of people from many far-off
lands and the government is innovative
to that created this a trap system which
is brand new and in full force but
ultimately stagnation sets in and within
two hundred years the Persian Empire has
succumb to the forces of other cultures
who have become stronger based on their
own ability to create innovate imagine
in this case we know that culture to be
the grease so we can sort of think of
this as autograph if we plot the
importance and influence of a society on
the y-axis and time on the x-axis we
sort of get like a bell curve sort of
shape rise and fall of civilizations if
you will and if we plot innovations but
the societies are responsible for in
these little red dots you know most of
them are to the left side of the peak
and after the peak not so much
innovation anymore coincidence I don't
think so take the immediate successor to
Persia the Greeks very similar we're
still familiar with a lot of their
contributions to a culture even our
culture today but they still could not
retain their ability to innovate and it
keeps going the Romans the byzantines
all the way up until take a look all the
way on the right over there looks pretty
familiar doesn't it we don't want this
to happen to us
do not let this happen to us so we just
looked at this arc of society and
civilization and remarkably it mirrors
the arc of our own lives we talked about
our experience in childhood and
adulthood take a moment now to try and
picture your own retirement you've
probably succeeded in a lot of things
you wanted to accomplish in life feeling
pretty good about yourself maybe you've
got a house off in the woods or on the
beach somewhere but the reality of it is
is that depression actually increases by
forty percent and what Americans retire
this is largely due to the fact that our
job is heavily tied to our creative
purpose additionally suicide rates
double for Americans of retirement age
65 to 85 this all sounds a bit morbid
but at a large and small scale the
failure to create is fatal now I want to
tease out this connection between
society and the individual a little bit
more obviously individuals drive society
and in a lot of cases these individuals
are are people who are committed and
motivated and working towards a goal but
we tend to remember a lot of people who
simply achieve and create because that's
what they like to do it's something that
really speaks to them people like this
might include Benjamin Franklin
Archimedes Leonardo da Vinci these guys
are luminaries but it can't just be up
to a small number of people to drive
society forward or to innovate create
it's up to all of us let's take a local
example so fackin oz work in my robotics
lab one of the guys in the lab would
come in with like this tub of Legos
every day you know this is a 27 year old
guy carrying his Legos
and hid build things with him on his
desk and what what are you doing but
those ended up being prototypes for some
of the best robots that he built and he
was unequivocally the best design
engineer in our lab he never lost his
inner kid he never lost his ability to
create to innovate for me my own
experience and build with building is
really important to me my parents used
to tell me when I was growing up do what
you enjoy and for me it was building
Lego towns like the one I was talking
about so I wanted to just keep doing
that but you get older and there's no
reason that this should stop no reason
innovating and creating and and just
having that sense of awe should stop in
high school I was part of my FIRST
Robotics team and we built this robot
here and I've since become an actual
robotics engineer and this robot is one
that we made for the DARPA Robotics
Challenge for disaster recovery
scenarios this robot is meant to save
lives so this is all very this is
inspiring to me it's something that
means a great deal to me and I found
those almost sort of current of
inspiration and fulfillment that's
skirting beneath the surface of our
lives and we just need to dig a little
bit to tap into it now for me I get that
through building and creating but we all
should seek to feel it immerse yourself
in creation and discovery the best way
to avoid personal stagnation by
extension societal stagnation is to end
to reach a higher state of fulfillment
is to dig into your passions and create
avoid the external the traps of external
validation be its status money power and
think about what you love
when you go to sleep tonight and put
your head on the pillow think about what
you did today that was new what what how
did that make you feel what will you
create tomorrow what will be new pitch
what will be new JD what are you going
to create and do it tap into your inner
current you depend on it and society
depends on it thank you